have you noticed things changing at 40
um i have yeah
yeah a lot of things are changing yeah
like random hairs like i mean yeah i'm
like
what oh those hairs
oh i was like do i need a razor like
what like i know you're like do i go to
the barber now like what is happening
with my face yeah that and also i'm in
the mirror going oh look at those blonde
natural oh my god
they're not that's not blonde it's great
what is that yeah and then do you pull
it do you not there there's a
controversy about pulling or not pulling
i know
i don't really pull it because i feel i
don't either i leave it i get my hair
only done i'm like literally ask them
like what can i do to only have to do
this twice a year me too because i don't
want to sit i don't want to do it all
the time and so i just leave them until
i get it done like whatever because it's
kind of like bonnie ray it's like cool
or like emmy lou harris it's like i feel
like i got a little cooler like fully
yeah and i really i'm hoping that i can
be brave and courageous enough that as i
get even older i can be that lady with
the white hair i see i don't i i hope i
can be that brave i think that we have
naturally the same color of hair maybe
now like a dirty blonde and i feel like
that's not in our cards i feel like
isn't that are you crushing my dreams
i'm so crushing it i feel like it's more
like really dark-haired women that go
really really bright like that yeah but
we can't yes but can't you we could dye
it can't you help it with some i will
help it some white highlights i will
help it i will also help you i will help
it on my way to helen mirren thank you i
just just that transitional moment might
be a little rough yeah it's okay maybe
we'll have another pandemic nobody will
see us
and we can blame it on that um i love
how many things were blamed on the
pandemic when we all naturally did them
in the frame we're like yeah i'm just
wearing this because i'm just like so
tired because the panda and i'm like i
wore that because it was tuesday so
that's why
[Music]
you